today on alternative views we have with
us two experts on the north american
free trade agreement which you may have
been seeing more and more about in the
mainstream press as the ratification
vote seems to be impending with us our
Christopher green a Harvard Law student
who's done research for the Texas Center
for Policy Studies and a former visitor
on alternative views James Scott a
public policy analyst with Public
Citizen my first questions for James
James has been quite a bit of urgency
associated with a NAFTA issue recently
why is it that the Clinton
administration seems so dead set on
pushing this issue through and ratifying
the agreement well only that the problem
with this is from the beginning been a
urgency placed upon this process by
external political forces President Bush
was under a quick timetable to get this
agreement finished before his election
and in order to help him gain votes in
states like Texas in California now
there is an urgency based on propping up
the government of President Carlos
Salinas in Mexico Salinas has his term
expires very soon and he needs to be
able to amass the political capital if
you will to within the pre party to
choose his successor the US has decided
that Salinas is our man and they they
feel that the US government feels that
if naff does not ratify it'll create a
backlash against Salinas who has
invested so much of his political
capital in this deal with the United
States
so the u.s. has decided that it needs to
just push through either the present US
administration is decided it needs to
push through the NAFTA agreement to sort
of save up to save Salinas from the
political risks he's taken but it seems
like there are some very vocal critics
of knapped in the US for instance Ross
Perot who's been against the north
this free free-trade agreement since the
beginning are there any political risks
or liabilities that President Clinton
may be taking upon himself
yeah President Clinton's taking some
very serious risks first and foremost is
the risk that as critics predict there
will be great job loss to Mexico as a
result of the north american free trade
agreement
this could be seen real clearly in the
example of what happened under the
us-canadian free trade agreement at that
time economic models predicted that
there would be job growth in Canada job
growth in u.s. just as these same
similar type models are trying to
predict now what happened in Canada was
manufacturing jobs fled to the US
they've lost several hundred thousand
jobs and much of that's due to the
recession of the worldwide recession but
a great deal of it was also due to the
u.s. Canadian free trade agreement
consequently president merle roni of
canada a prime minister Mulroney I'm
sorry became very very unpopular he had
popularity ratings which he would be
very envious of someone like Richard
Nixon at the height of Watergate because
he he and his party were perceived to
have caused to lost a hundred thousands
hundreds of thousands of jobs through
the free trade deal with the US
consequently this agreement was rushed
through in Canada before the upcoming
elections which the ruling party that
Mulroney parties is surely to lose also
people have cited environmental concerns
about the impact of NAFTA aside from the
impact on jobs could you tell me what
the general environmental concerns are
both of you essentially the concerns
fall into two basic categories one is
concern over effects on US environmental
laws under NAFTA as with other
international trade agreements a law
which inhibits trade can be challenged
and struck down as a trade barrier in
the US has many many environmental laws
which extend beyond our borders they
affect pesticide residues
they affect the importation of
endangered species some states may
choose to prohibit the export of timber
an effort to manage the forests more
successfully what this means is if the
US is to pass a law which impedes trade
in any way with one of the partners
Canada or Mexico or if a state or a
county or a local government does the
same the other parties to NAFTA can
challenge and that law will be struck
down we've seen examples of this into
the current GATT right now Europe is
challenging the US on corporate average
fuel economy standards corporate and
this is under the GATT a general
agreement on tariffs and trade NAFTA is
like a little brother to get and NAFTA
invests a lot of authority in dispute
resolution panel consists of five trade
lawyers who will decide whether or not a
US law can be struck down so it puts us
sovereignty in the hands of lawyers
exactly private groups exactly and it
and it threatens many of the laws that
we as environmentalists have fought for
years and years through a democratic
process to achieve the thought that
these laws can be struck down at the
whim of a panel of Trade bureaucrats is
very disconcerting to most
environmentalists the second issue that
we have of concern to us is the issue of
companies fleeing the United States to
avoid US environmental restrictions and
using Mexico as a dumping ground
polluting the air including the water
which in many cases comes back over here
currently there's a maquiladoras raid
zone it's been in existence since late
60s along the us-mexico border pollution
there is abysmal these companies don't
adhere to anywhere near the pollution
control requirements they're required to
do here in this country and these plants
have attracted tens or hundreds of
thousands of people from the interior of
Mexico to these towns on the border
where basic infrastructure is just not
adequate there are no water treatment
plants
there is inadequate sewage treatment
there's no and many of these Colonials
which surround these plants there's no
running water there is no electricity
and it's very disconcerting to see when
you go down there as I've done the
richest corporations in the world GM you
know it's a who's who General Electric
surrounded by shanty towns of the people
who work for them who are living in
basically in squalor so there's a lot of
environmental pressures population
pressures and an area that's very arid
has very little water to start with and
would what it does have is now being
polluted through chemicals from these
plants and from sewage from the shanty
towns that surround these plants Chris
you recently authored a report called
the Carbone to dilemma a case study of
the failings of us-mexico environmental
management in the border region this has
to do with power generation in the
region just south of Big Bend National
Park well yeah actually the plant itself
is going to be about 20 miles south at
Google Pass Texas and the the way the
air flow goes because of the Gulf will
blow all of the emissions from this
power plant into Big Bend and the aroldo
karremans site in northern Mexico the
planet itself is very large
it's about 1,400 megawatts and there's
an existing it's called carbon 2 there's
an existing plant at the site called
carbon one which many US agencies only
just found out about towed together this
facility will be over 2600 megawatts by
comparison the large Navajo Generating
Station in the in the West is only about
2000 megawatt so it's very as large a
facility as exists in the US and will
definitely be the largest energy
facility in the border region what
substances these plants used to produce
energy well the plans carbon one is
coal-fired using moderate sulfur high
ash low BTU coal
hello BTU meaning you have to burn a lot
of this to get the energy content so
therefore you create more
emissions of various pollutants sulfur
dioxide the high ash will mean there's a
lot of particulate matter nitrogen
oxides and others and the problem is
carbon one has no controls for no
environmental controls whatsoever
the proposed carbon 2 project which is
about half built supposedly will have
protection for for particulates although
those are those won't be be that
effective because they remove only a
very narrow range and don't don't remove
the small particles 10 microns unless
that causes a vast majority of
visibility damage and also sulfur
dioxide there are no controls for sulfur
dioxide on the carbon to plant which is
the leading cause of visibility damage
what companies are responsible for
bringing these plants into being and
also if I'm not mistaken isn't a very
fairly desolate uh where's this power
going to be that's a good question
there's will the cut the plant itself is
being built by the Commission federal de
electricidad which is Mexico's Energy
Agency basically the rumored to be close
to bankrupt so they sought financing to
complete this project there's a
consorted it's going to be sold
hopefully well hopefully on their part
to consortium of businesses one is it's
called Energon and it is comprised of
alto Hornos which is a steel operation
in Mexico which will receive 10% of the
output of the planet for its one of its
steel mills in nearby Monclova
and the other part of mexican partner is
Macari a mining conglomerates who
expects to provide most of the five
million tons of coal needed per year for
this plant they will own 51% of the
operation the other 49% would be owned
by a group called mission energy which
is itself a subsidiary of SCE Corp which
owns Southern California Edison all
these groups are somewhat suspect
makaras had some problems with labor
operations at their minds Alto [ __ ]
knows who was recently
I don't know the correct correct status
but it was chastised by the US
government and I think there's actually
federal action for their dumping Mexican
steel on the US market now under NAFTA
there wouldn't be any possibility of
such charges I'd be able to just sell
steel in the US market as much as they
wanted uh primarily yeah but there's
still a problem with dumping your
stalled under NAFTA and yet you're still
not allowed to sell a product in another
country at a lower price than you then
it cost to produce it or that you sell
it it would sell it in your host country
but that the second part of that is I
mean they say lower pricing you're
selling your house country but that's
it's hard that's hard it's really not
enforced that much but the production is
still people people still pay attention
to what about mission energy what
interest do they have in this plant well
that's that's interesting de se Corp
which owns as I said Owens mission and
and Southern California Edison Southern
California Edison prides itself on being
a quote unquote green utility and they
made big deal of publicizing their
different different efficiency programs
and that made a big fact that they're
going to lower their carbon dioxide
emissions by a certain percentage and
they've advertised the photo highly
that's part of the green campaign
courtesy from a lot of major US
corporations sure where they tout their
environmental concern and how they're
helping out being good corporate
citizens certainly a lot of people
bought it because interestingly the the
CEO of se Corp is John Bryson who was
when the original cofounders of NRDC the
Natural Resources Defense Council one of
the meeting advocates of an
environmental litigation they well
anyway so some while while Southern
California Edison are making these
claims their other arm mission energy in
the name itself implies they're going
into third world nations and setting up
these large-scale power plants many of
which do not have environmental controls
such entities in Indonesia Malaysia
Thailand
on several other countries they've got
similar operations they such as an in
annual report for last year of sed
corpses if they've invested 310 million
dollars for the plant and associated
coal resources Carbone - yeah will the
plug carbon to plant and so it's not
sure what the Associated coal resources
means there's an additional issue which
is set a whole separate sub issue but
right now a company called dos Republic
is trying to set up a open pit strip
mined for coal in Eagle Pass itself
actually within the community boundaries
that that itself is a whole other
environmental catastrophe opens pit
strip mining is so it's almost never
reclaimed that the land is almost never
reclaimed turns out there could be a
alluvial in terms of the it's very close
to to the Rio Grande Rio Bravo region
the watershed a lot of the runoff from
this mountain mining operation will go
right into there and further pollute
they already devastated Rio Grande so so
it's not sure exactly but in the
ownership certain claims have been made
by the mayor of Eagle Pass and others
that there is an ownership connection
between doe super bukas and Mission
energy or the other consortium and this
is this is all to display coal to carbon
to although publicly that's always
denied by the companies and it's still
not sure what what the true deal is
they're here you have mission energy an
arm of the very green energy US energy
company SCE corporation operating a
power plant about 20 miles from the US
border what measures are they taken to
protect the US environment because it
seems like there's going to be a lot of
overflow from this plant into the u.s.
let alone the Mexican environment well
mission makes no excuses for its
operations in other countries they Tom
read the project manned missions project
manager for the carbon to plant has
outright said that mission considers
itself under no obligation to meet US
standards and doesn't they don't think
that they even have to provide the EPA
with any information on the plant's
operation capacity or emissions
because they're not on u.s. territory
they're mere 20 miles from the US border
but they still they still say that more
importantly the pollution from this
plant will blow all directly into Big
Bend and it's not just a case of US
citizens saying well Mexico's developing
and it's going to affect our beautiful
scenery the levels the emission levels
of sulfur dioxide particulates are so
high from this plant that they will they
exceed the sulfur dioxide exceeds even
basic human health standards for the
Piedras Negras area Eagle Pass area also
many many crops species are killed at
very low levels of sulfur dioxide and
there's a lot of crop development and
irrigation that goes on in that region
also the US has set standards for
industrial development tied to the level
of sulfur dioxide in the air could these
high levels of sulfur dioxide have an
effect on industrial development in the
US on the other side of the border
certainly and that's that's the that's a
primary worry of us industrialist
there's certain increments that are
called set out in the Clean Air Act
where they allow they make each each
region basically state set up its own
implementation plan on how they're going
to deal with their air quality that was
one way of decentralizing the issue any
give certain certain allowances and this
this sulfur dioxide will blow into the
US and will exceed the allowances for
Big Bend National there's also
additional standards for siting near a
class one protected national park and
this the emissions projected emissions
from the carbon to plant will exceed
those by 300% at Big Bend so not only
will that could that hinder any future
development in the US or Mexican border
region that they want to develop in the
region their emissions will not be
allowed to add anymore but it could also
require existing US facilities to reduce
their emissions below what they're
presently allowed to to release
if this power plant were in the u.s.
what would be required of it a number of
things one one is for starters it's just
highly unlikely that he would even be
allowed to be sighted this close to a
protected National Park it's only 100
miles from Big Bend and I said
everything will blow directly there but
the the basic they said the the
estimated emissions of sulfur dioxide
will be from this plant the carbon tree
plant alone will be around two point
three six pounds per million Btu by
comparison the u.s. standard is 1.2
pounds per million and that's that's a
maximum EPA standard in addition to that
there's a standard requiring best
available control technology under that
that would require reduction of
emissions by another 90% a typical plant
as I said two points two point three six
pounds per million Btu is what carbon 2
will put out a typical plant right now
in the US if it were built those built
today would be held to about point 1 to
point 2 pounds per million Btu we're
talking at least an order of magnitude
here 10 to 20 times the amount of
pollution a u.s. facility would put out
we've heard a lot in the press
especially on alternative views about
the u.s. environmental concerns with
nafta for instance pollution coming over
from Mexico or from US companies
especially operating into Mexico into
the United States does Mexico have any
environmental concerns that they are
addressing the US on citizens of Mexico
are the Mexican government's not there
recently has been a lot of stir over the
siting of nuclear waste facilities and
other types of toxic hazardous waste
facilities along the US border everybody
knows that it's quite common in this
country for facilities to be sited where
there's going to be the least public
resistance the people who are least
empowered in this country typically
get the worst of the environmental
dumping that's very clear in
southwestern Texas people they're
largely Hispanic or rural they are not
politically empowered and consequently
many many many dumps are sited in that
region also with the coming of NAFTA
there's gonna be a great deal more
pressure for for people for companies to
enforce the provisions of bringing toxic
waste from the maquiladoras back to the
United States currently they just dump
it bring it back to the United States
for dumping so that's another reason
there's a lot of these waste dumps sited
along the border I heard recently that
the u.s. is putting a radioactive waste
dump near the Mexican border is there
any concern about this and what are the
specifics of the issue exactly uh well
as I was saying frequently there's a lot
of these dumps in that area we share the
same error we share the same water share
the same watersheds aquifers and
recently the proposed nuclear waste
facility at Sierra Blanca has has been
challenged and and just not long ago
several hundred Mexican residents came
to the state of Texas came to Austin to
pose deciding that dump there at Sierra
Blanca this is a nuclear waste dump
right right a nuclear waste facility
people there the citizens are clearly
concerned they don't have a official
mechanism to address their grievances
they came up they held a rally they
tried to make their concerns known but
as of yet there's been no formal inquiry
from New Mexican environmental agencies
and so the people are basically it's
very grassroots movement and they're
very much on their own and it's a lot of
hands being you know held across borders
now a lot of brothers and sisters who
live on
size of the borders both you're worried
about these these sightings because they
affect everybody I think in fairness you
should say that at the the actual
hearing for that for that radioactive
waste site what it was it was it was
going to accept the residue from uranium
mining so it's it's not only is it
radioactive waste but it's a lot of
heavy duty solvents put in to separate
the uranium from from the ore but Mexico
did send a member of Congress who came
up and spoke and actually opposed
formally opposed the foreign formally
opposed the the issuing of this permit
for them to build this plant and it's
actually the one of the first times that
a Mexican government official has come
and taken an active part in a u.s.
proceeding on a environmental border
dispute it seems that in a very complex
economic issue well in the very complex
economic issues that are going to evolve
the north american free trade agreement
well there'll be literally thousands of
relocations and movements across the
border that there needs to be some sort
of formal mechanism for people to
operate in not just an informal sending
of an official or something like that
and i'm wondering what your take is on
the side agreements that the clinton
administration recently released having
to do with economic and labor issues are
they going to create that kind of
mechanism that's needed are they levy
going to alleviate the situation at all
these side agreements fall way short of
doing anything like addressing problems
similar to the one we've seen at carbon
two at most of what is they'll in
summary what is done is they're creating
a commission on the environment this is
a cooperation council all the language
we've seen has been thing has used
language that's non-binding all attempts
to cooperate attempts to studies
commission studies to look into issues
to share information but as far as
anything with teeth anything that would
actually give the American citizens or
Mexican citizens a right to have their
grievances heard about a sighting of a
facility for example
there's nothing like that or in the in
terms of teeth penalties against
corporations who are bad actors there's
nothing with any real enforcement and
the La Paz agreements a good example of
what happens when you don't have an
agreement that that means something
these side agreements are very vague
very wishy-washy and they don't really
mean anything Chris could you tell us
about the La Paz agreement what its
history is and give us some examples of
how legal issues across across the
border might be handled in the future La
Paz agreement is called so for the place
of its signing in 1988 by President
Ronald Reagan and president de la Madrid
of Mexico and it was the first time
border issues border environmental
problems were recognized and addressed
addresses is their term they it sets out
several vague mandates on we should
cooperate in the future
it's basically an agree agreement to
agree again in the future
there has been some good things that
have come out of it such as these
separate technical annexes to deal with
specific problems such as waste water
pollution isolated incidents smelters of
copper and other other ores that put a
ton of sulfur dioxide into the air and
that has been somewhat effective in
those specific technical annexes but the
agreement itself doesn't contain a whole
lot a lot of people say that it's great
because it it mandates sharing of
information between US agencies and
environmental agencies and the Mexican
environmental agencies but that's not
really true it says that they should
cooperate in the future and shall
consider information exchanges such as
there's nothing actually requiring the
agencies to share information and they
don't with with the carbon to plant the
US EPA asked for a copy of the
environmental impact statement done on
the by the Mexican government on the
plant back I think in April and I still
have yet to get a reply and similarly on
the US side the US mexico requested the
EP u.s. epa to get involved with these
siting of these
two active websites under you in the US
side of the border and EPA would take no
involvement I'll provide more
information so you see there isn't
really a hit strong history of
cooperation there and that is sort of
what the side agreements are relying
upon saying well we should set up this
pattern for negotiation for agreement in
the future cooperation
it's unsure that's very unclear whether
that cooperation will actually happen
what consumer or environmental groups
have been included in the constitution
of the side agreements has it been an
attempt to include the ordinary people
or people citizens groups in this
process not our groups that's for sure
I'm not clear on if they have consulted
I know the process was closed and
secretive just as the negotiation of the
original nafta text was from from my
understanding citizens don't really have
a place in either the negotiations
process or the dispute resolution
process after there has been a charge of
a bad actor in one of the three
countries if they are involved I would
say that they did their demands used to
go in heated with the integrated
recently in 92 thinking about the
integrated environmental border plan and
what that was is basically viewed as a
temporary pacifier to quell critics of
NAFTA to ease its ratification in the
u.s. there were a lot of concerns when
it was being developed that US
environmental groups put forth saying
there is no there are no solid
enforcement measures in here there is no
identify there's I think of the 87
identifiable commitments that were made
in that agreement over half of them
amounted to as I said to agree again in
a future hold a meeting another 17% were
to conduct studies and so forth only 6%
of the 87 identifiable commitments
actually decided to address a problem
and so if there is any input it
generally just goes
you know that that can be seen the fact
that the lack of input from
environmentalists or consumers you know
can be seen what the outcome of this was
what they've agreed to is the creation
of this commission which will only deal
enforcement wise with non enforcement of
a country's own domestic environmental
laws in other words the Commission will
only take any kind of action if a
country is not enforcing its own
environmental laws what's to stop a
company a US company say from going
right across the border and sending all
kinds of pollution out into the air and
ground a pollution that may actually
come into the u.s. well as far as this
the side agreements that kind of
question points to a glaring weakness
according to the side agreements the
only thing that that's even enforceable
act at all after an arduous journey
through a maze of procedures to get to a
cause of action the only thing that's
enforceable at all is a country's non
enforcement of its own environmental
laws clearly Mexico has a number of good
environmental laws on the books on the
US does the US and Canada however we
feel like that's a pretty weak standard
to go by if that's the only thing that's
that has any kind of enforcement
mechanism at all
clearly with carbon 2 they are complying
with Mexican environmental laws to our
knowledge they can send out all the
sulfur dioxide they want to the air of
other I think solid particulates were
just cited as when the largest causes of
cancer in the US and as long as it
doesn't break Mexican laws it can come
over into the National Park across the
border it can go into write Utah Texas
New Mexico and there's nothing we can do
well and even if it were to break
Mexican laws it would take a pattern of
not enforcement over a great period of
time there's no timeline on any of this
for procedures of us redress dressing
the grievances there it would it require
both the US and Canada to agree to bring
some kind of action
and then it's very vague as to what that
action would be more than this
commission on the environment
encouraging Mexico to start enforcing
its own law and even then Mexico is
having problems enforcing its laws as it
is they made a big deal about the fact a
good deal has been made about how
they've hired all these additional
environmental investigators and
inspectors on the border region but
article at times came out last week it
should they hadn't paid any of these
people for five months so of the several
hundred that they two hundred that they
hired they're now down to a handful
because they haven't been paid
additionally although they the amount of
inspectors had doubled during the past
two years the GAO reported that the
amount of permits applied for in Mexico
has quadrupled not only that but none of
the selected sites that were inspected
by the GAO had actually applied for the
permits themselves so permits have
quadrupled and the vast majority aren't
even applying for permits it's estimated
right now less than three percent of all
industry industrial facilities in Mexico
have the necessary permits and that's
any regarding that the the nafta
implications we don't know i there with
with the the carbon to plant under
NAFTA's provisions it is likely that
this plant will be able to sell power
back into the US and that is one of the
fundamental core problems with the idea
of free trade or as it should be known
just deregulated international commerce
there's nothing nothing free about it
it's it can affect the problem is when a
nation will internalize its
environmental costs as a US does through
it regulation of the emissions and other
other ways they're making a certain
societal statement on how they want
their economy to evolve when you open up
trade when you deregulate trade across
international
Riis it's going to favor the country
that doesn't internalize its
environmental costs so this system could
set up this US company mission even
though the company is based in the u.s.
set up this power plant in Mexico and in
cell power with no environmental
controls and then so power back into the
u.s. at a cost lower than companies
facilities that have to comply with the
u.s. environmental standards how it can
sell it how could this apply to things
like food and whatnot we regulate the
amount of pesticides in our food we
passed a law banning the consumption of
tuna that was caught with a dolphin
dangerous net so well what sort of a
fallout can we see from well people
people say that these problems will
never happen into these trade agreements
that there's no way we'd ever actually
lower our standards people would go
people wouldn't wouldn't stand for it
the problem is it's not that blatant
it's a lot more covert with the tuna the
way they rectify the tuna case was they
passed something called the Marine
Mammal Protection Act which actually the
exact opposite it removed several marine
mammals from protection and with such as
instances of food that's a big issue
with with international trade is the
amount of pesticides are included on
food and although it says in in some of
the agreements get and then Ana NAFTA
that they will not be allowed to import
things that don't meet the USA's own
standards those standards can be
challenged and even if they're not
challenged to say with pesticides the
u.s. is now is also again recently the
times that the u.s. is itself
considering lifting its ban on the
addition of cancer-causing substances to
food saying that it will cause us to ban
too many pesticides but there might be a
more sinister element to that in that
it's going to open it up for for trade
from Mexico so if if the pesticides do
you think that there could be subtle
political pressure put in through the
free-trade agreement to lift certain
bands like the ban on DDT or whatnot
that we share on food consumption
certainly because it's not going to be
the countries that are there are
challenging these bands it's going to be
the US corporations who stand to profit
the band being lifted well taking
another tack people say that there's
going to be an economic crisis in Mexico
if NAFTA isn't passed what do you think
about this
well Mexico is in a pretty precarious
position right now as it is right now
the Mexican government has undertaken a
policy of low wages and keeping the peso
overvalued at some point they're going
going to have to devalue the peso
whether that's before after NAFTA is
ratified we don't know this is going to
cause some disruptions in Mexico
whether NAFTA gets passed or not there
are certain problems inherent in this
speculative bubble that's going on in
Mexico
that are going to cause some disruptions
whether that should be a concern to us
policymakers is a good question I think
that we know there are problems with
structural problems with the Mexican
economy caused by the policies of the
flames government policies which have
been tracked attracted a great deal of
capital in flight from other countries
to finance - finance debt payment of the
debt and to maintain some of these large
growth projects now if naff does not
ratified it's there's a good chance that
this speculative bubble on the mexican
stock market might actually burst the
ramifications to the mexican people are
not real real clear now
with or without NAFTA you have to
remember that bubble is going to burst
when the peso is devalued capital is
going to flow back out when the peso is
devalued the US trade surplus with
Mexico will likely reverse itself into
again a trade deficit with Mexico these
are some some pretty technical issues
that
that people within the Mexican
government have been battling over for
quite some time
political timing economic timing it's
all tied in together the question needs
to be looked at in terms of how that
should be dealt with in the US policy
debate do we have a responsibility to
prop up this regime in Mexico are we
going to base the decisions that are
going to affect hundreds of thousands of
US workers on whether or not the Mexican
stock market bubble bursts now or six
months from now you know those are some
questions that I think the answer to is
we need to go on with our policy debate
looking at what's in the best interest
of the environment what's in the best
interest of US workers and indeed what's
in the best interest probably of the
vast majority of workers within Mexico
not based on what's in the interest of
stockholders and banks who've invested a
high AO invested speculatively in a
market driven by promises and a whimsy
from what the two of you said it seems
like NAFTA is only going to benefit one
class of benefit people or even non
people that's corporations and their
stockholders you painted a picture where
the ratification agreement will create
environmental chaos and the border a lot
of pollution coming into the u.s. that
we haven't had in the past and a
dislocation possibly of Mexican workers
as well as US workers so I'd like to ask
each of you what do you think can be
done to fix this agreement if anything
Chris well I think at the vid to fix the
agreement is arguments whether the
agreement should be fixed at all but or
scrapped but to fix agree at very least
you would need to put some solid
enforcement measures saying if there is
an environmental challenge a problem
that that can be challenged publicly by
citizens and that there be a specific
means of addressing those problems
additionally that when a problem really
problem comes up and it's caused by a
certain actor that actor will be able to
be directly fine rather than finding an
already a government that already has it
so significant over demand on its
resources by finding the Mexican
government you're not going to have a
direct effect on a Dow Chemical Company
that's pumping pumping pollution in the
Rio Grande also you should set up you
should make all matters completely open
to public disclosure under under this
present supplemental Accords any
information about an environmental
infringement can be withheld by consent
of the other two parties so it won't
take long for these parties to realize
that they're all doing something bad at
some point and then agreeing to just ban
the public release of this information
in nature that's what President Lee
happens in the La Paz agreement no
information can be made available to the
public without the consent of both
parties and so both parties never
consent to have any information released
additional lastly I would I would make
sure that there is a way to clean up the
border region and in one proposed
measures development of a multilateral
Development Bank a new one separate from
the World Bank - to lend money to
certain groups to go in and clean up
some of the problems that's that's
that's in the Supplemental Accords it's
not sure that could be a good idea if
it's done well but you've really got to
ensure that it's not just a mechanism by
one company goes in and profits from
polluting another company goes and
profits from cleaning up and the US
taxpayers through the Development Bank
just share any risk of the corporate
corporate action and you've got it
you've got to look at these situations
you've got to look at these these vague
Accords in the in a supplemental
agreement in their worst possible case
scenario whether you look at it under
the cliche while the Clinton
administration they might be well
accessed I mean depends on whether you
read the Clinton administration as a
honeymoon as some have or as a date-rape
as other have others have I imagine
worst case scenario four or five years
down the road
Phil Gramm in charge of this agency
that's going to be required to pursue
these environmental environmental
infringement as we saw you know with the
interior ministry under Reagan if the
executive the place is too much hands
too much power in the hands of the
executive branch in power at that time
so you see this you see that NAFTA is
just another way of the ordinary
citizens ceding their sovereignty seeing
their rights to regulate their own
environment and government to government
agencies sure that's it that's yes and
it's exactly that's a whole thing of
that's a whole the whole goal of some of
these these uh deregulation of
international commerce agreements
there's always been regulation that's
the term free trade there's all that
that's how regulation got started to
begin with was to protect the government
being responsive to the needs of the
citizens to protect them from the the
actions of profit-seeking corporations
who are less likely to to observe social
and environmental matters James what's
your take on these issues is there
anything salvageable about NAFTA or
useful in it well that the concept is
useful in international agreements which
open borders it can be done right I
frankly don't think there's anything
salvageable about this NAFTA they're
going to have to take it back scrap it
and start all over again
there's too many fundamental problems
like even with the development of a
Development Bank what that's going to
wind up doing is putting US taxpayers in
charge of cleaning up a mess caused by
US corporations so in other words the
corporation's get not only to throw
workers out of work move the jobs across
the border start polluting the border
region and then here comes the US
taxpayers to to clean up the mess but a
more fundamental problem with that is
development banks banks are used to
their profit seeking and cleaning up
pollution is not exactly a very
profitable venture
what they're going to do is issue bonds
to to finance this border cleanup well I
don't know about you but if I'm looking
to invest money you're going to do it
where there's a return so I very
distinct fear and that this Development
Bank will be used to develop
infrastructure needs and things to help
commerce things that have a payback and
the the actual cleanup of toxic sand
things like that will get left undone
because the municipalities cannot afford
to pay back a Development Bank works by
being paid back these municipalities
can't afford to clean up their own mess
right now or the mess that's caused by
the US corporations it's very unlikely
they're going to have the money to make
this a profitable venture and that these
bonds will inevitably be defaulted on
and and and they're backed up by the US
taxpayer who according to the models
that have been shown will be responsible
for picking up the tab there's a default
now after having said all this none of
this is even on paper yet with the
announcement of the side agreements they
talked about this concept of a
Development Bank but even the the
concepts that I've just discussed even
none of them have actually even been put
down so I think we're real unlikely to
get even that much when all is said and
done so my feeling is start over again
development concept Development Bank
concept is a good idea rich country
should put something into helping the
cleanup of the mess but I would see it
funded more from a mechanism by which
the corporation's who benefit from
moving jobs across the border but they
themselves they're benefiting from free
trade they should be paying for this
clean up well US taxpayers look out
sounds like free trade free trade in the
90s sounds a lot like deregulation in
the 80s it seems like our government and
the big corporations that support it
that give the money for the politicians
that are fighting so hard for NAFTA
now both here and in Mexico are just
looking for another way to stop up
profits and to issue bonds it'll never
get repaid and once again the US
taxpayer in the end is going to have to
foot the bill